From ingredients to portion sizes,
we wanted to know all the differences
between Shake Shack and In-N-Out.
This is "Food Wars."
This isn't a standard "Food Wars" episode.
We're pitting two different
US chains against each other,
which means we're going to do
things slightly differently.
We're going to be keeping score as we go,
and at the end, we'll decide objectively
which chain is the best.
Here's everything you can
get at an In-N-Out Burger.
Here's everything you
can get at a Shake Shack.
I'm going to make a case
on why I think the
In-N-Out menu is better.
I've been to a lot of In-N-Outs,
I've been to a lot of Shake Shacks,
but today, I am going to make the case
as to why I think the Shake
Shack menu is just better.
But the points will be awarded
by our independent referee,
which should be Harry
popping in somewhere.
You are absolutely right, Nico.
To make sure this is fair,
I'm going to step in
as the neutral referee.
I want a nice, clean fight.
Let's go.
Obviously these are two
different restaurants,
so everything is going to be an exclusive.
But we're going to start
off with the burgers.
The Shake Shack burgers consist of
the cheeseburger, hamburger,
the ShackBurger, which
is my personal favorite,
bacon cheeseburger, the
SmokeShack, the shroom burger,
the Shack Stack, which is a shroom burger
and a regular burger stacked
on top of each other.
I am not the biggest fan of mushrooms,
but it looks pretty good.
This is a huge burger.
The shroom part of this
Shack Stack looks empty.
It looks really empty in there.
It looks hollow.
It tastes really, really good.
I'm very surprised, because I
really don't like mushrooms,
but this works really well
with the regular patty.
Because I'm having a hard time
finding the mushroom in the Shack Stack,
I do kind of want to taste
the shroom burger on its own
to see if it's any more obvious.
The shroom burger on its own is definitely
a lot more mushroomy,
but still, I feel like
the main flavor you get
is of whatever this crispy coating is,
which tastes pretty delicious.
In-N-Out has fewer burger options,
but they also have a not-so-secret menu
with even more burgers.
These first three are on
the official In-N-Out menu.
Starting down here, we got the hamburger,
and of course, cheeseburger.
This to me is probably
what I get every time.
I like the cheese with the onions.
Yeah.
Then the Double-Double, or
the double cheeseburger.
Next, we have the Veggie Shack.
I also want to take a bite of this.
I feel like this is just
another one of those cases
where I'm not really
getting the full flavor
of the patty, because everything else
is kind of overwhelming.
The pickles and the fried
onions is mainly what I taste.
Then we have the avocado bacon burger.
Believe it or not, there
is avocado in here.
We also have a new burger,
which is the spicy ShackMeister.
It has cherry peppers in it,
some fried onion, and a seasoning.
I don't think I know anything
about cherry peppers.
They kind of taste a little bit pickled.
There's just like a
little brininess to them
that's actually pretty tasty.
Now the not-so-secret
menu has the double meat.
That's two beef patties.
You do protein style,
which replaces the buns with lettuce.
animal-style, which, animal-style is
Thousand Island dressing,
diced onions, and pickles.
I don't like pickles,
but Thousand Island
dressing and diced onions,
let's go.
The vinegariness of the pickles
with the Thousand Island and the onions,
very nice.
Very nice addition.
And, as seen before,
the 3x3
and the 4x4,
which is three patties of
meat, three slices of cheese,
or four patties of meat,
four slices of cheese.
Come on, guys.
If you're getting this,
you're just showing off.
I would argue you're better off
getting two double cheeseburgers
than the four-by-four.
I think Shake Shack gets one point
for having more options.
I think selection is a good thing.
I'm almost tempted to
deduct a point from In-N-Out
for that lettuce burger,
but I'll let it slide for now.
Apparently a quad burger with four patties
existed at some point
on the unofficial Shake Shack secret menu.
The option to add more
patties seems to be gone now,
so we're just going to
Frankenstein our own quad burger.
All right, I can do it. OK.
Don't look at me.
Everyone turn around.
I would never order that.
That's just like, way too much meat
to be enjoyable right now.
But it is possible.
Anything is possible.
Moving on to the chicken options.
Shake Shack offers the
avocado bacon chicken,
the Chicken Shack, the hot chicken,
and chicken bites,
which look really, really good.
I actually haven't seen
a spicy chicken sandwich
on their menu for a while.
I feel like this is a recent addition,
so I do want to taste it.
That's a really good chicken sandwich.
I feel like a lot of people
sleep on the chicken
options at Shake Shack.
They're all really, really good.
And I do feel like this looks more filling
than their regular burgers.
It just looks like a
hardy piece of chicken.
I do want to try one of
the chicken bites, too.
I'm going to use some Shack sauce.
I'm a dipper.
I need sauce always.
They're good. They're just a lot saltier
than the chicken patties
in any of their chicken sandwiches,
which is confusing to me.
If you're in the mood for chicken,
do not come to In-N-Out,
because they have none.
In-N-Out hasn't changed
the menu since 1976,
so I don't think they're planning on
adding chicken to the menu anytime soon.
In-N-Out's small menu
seems to be working out for
them really well, though.
They make everything fresh,
so it probably helps simplifying
day-to-day operations.
Plus, bigger menus means increased costs.
You made a pretty good case there, Joe,
but I think Shake Shack
still gets one point
for having chicken options.
We also have a couple non-burger options.
There's a grilled cheese and a BLT.
I love when a restaurant
makes their sandwiches
with grilled burger buns.
The grilled cheese with the burger buns
is very elite to me,
and I don't know why.
It just tastes really good.
It's extra buttery, extra delicious.
I don't know what it is.
In-N-Out also has a grilled cheese.
It's pretty much the only
vegetarian menu item they have
that isn't a side or a milkshake.
If you're not in the mood for a burger,
Shake Shack also has hot dogs.
They started out as a hot dog place,
so it's kind of cool that they've
held onto the tradition
of making hot dogs.
You'll notice that they
slice their hot dogs
right down the middle.
This method helps cook
the hot dogs more evenly.
I personally love the split hot dogs.
I love all the
caramelization that you get.
But I don't think Joe is a fan.
Yeah, split hot dog, I hate it.
Completely pointless.
It doesn't change the taste of it at all.
Flag on the play.
Look at the state of that hot dog.
No points for that one.
For sides, we've got fries, cheese fries,
bacon cheese fries,
spicy fries with ranch,
and spicy cheese fries with ranch.
These are new to the menu.
I don't know if they're going
to be permanent forever,
but we were able to get them today.
We as a nation just cannot stay
away from the ranch, can we?
I've never even heard of
ranch and fries together,
not even as a dipping
sauce with regular fries.
Oh my God, no.
I've never heard of that.
I kind of want to try the fry
without the ranch first. Hold on.
It's that same spicy seasoning
that we saw on that chicken sandwich
and on one of the burgers.
It is really spicy
when it's so liberally applied.
I do think that these fries
are definitely better with
the ranch than without it,
and it also helps tame
some of that spiciness.
This is interesting.
I don't know if I'm fully sold
on dipping fries in ranch,
but it doesn't taste bad.
In-N-Out does have fries,
and I'm sorry,
but this is where In-N-Out
suddenly becomes not so great.
You can get various customizations
and secret menu ones.
The fries, ugh. Just avoid them.
Right here are the regular fries.
Let's take a bite.
Terrible.
Also get the animal-style fries.
Onion, Thousand Island, cheese.
Better.
You can also ask for fries well done,
where I think they cook them twice
or just make them extra crispy.
They're not,
the problem is they're not very salty.
You also got cheese fries.
Not bad.
Yeah, because there's cheese on them.
You can also get something
called roadkill fries,
which is animal-style plus a beef patty.
I asked there,
and the guy said he can
give you animal-style
and a beef patty,
I got to make it myself, whatever.
Also, lemon pepper
fries, where it's, again,
just you take a lemon wedge
and squeeze it on your fries,
and then pepper them.
I'm not doing that.
I'm not the first person to say it:
These fries are not good.
I like the animal-style,
and I like the cheese fries,
because they both have
cheese on it and sauce
and fun stuff.
But, yeah, these fries,
not only are they weak,
but they're bland and dry.
No good.
Joe, you're not doing a very good job
of advocating for In-N-Out there.
I'm going to have to give
Shake Shack the point.
Those fries look better.
It's time for sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
For exclusive sauces, we
only have the Shack sauce.
The real sauce recipe is a secret,
but they give a close-enough recipe
in the Shake Shack cookbook.
This sauce contains Hellmann's mayonnaise,
Dijon mustard, Heinz ketchup,
kosher dill pickling brine - interesting -
and cayenne pepper.
I think the Shake Shack sauce
is a really good burger sauce
that just works well with any food.
In-N-Out has their own
special sauce known as spread.
And the recipe is top secret,
but there are a bunch of
copycat recipes out there.
That is what's part of the animal-style,
and we saw it on some
of the burgers earlier.
It is possible the sauce contains mayo,
ketchup, sweet pickle relish,
and white-wine vinegar.
It tastes exactly like
Thousand Island dressing.
Those sauces just sound the same.
You can both have a point.
As for soft drinks, Shake Shack offers
Coke, Diet Coke, Dr Pepper, Fanta orange,
Sprite, Ginger Ale, Coke
Zero, Draft root beer,
Shack-made lemonade, 50/50 lemonade,
which is half ice tea, half lemonade,
strawberry lemonade,
and dragonfruit pomegranate lemonade,
which you can order caffeinated.
And you can also get organic
Harney & Sons ice tea,
and Honest Kids organic apple juice.
I am a lemonade lover.
I really like the lemonade at Shake Shack.
But what I am interested in trying
is this new harvest berry lemonade.
These are caffeinated.
They have a few different flavors.
And they have all these odd ingredients
that I've just never heard put together.
Here are those ingredients.
Cinnamon was the ingredient
that really jumped out at me,
because I'm like, cinnamon in my lemonade?
That's kooky.
It has a slightly medicinal taste
that reminds me of tea,
but not a fun iced tea.
Just when you're sick
and you're drinking tea.
But it's not bad.
I can definitely taste the cinnamon,
and it's a little off-putting,
because of the tartness,
and then I get the cinnamon.
I don't know.
It's not super working
well together for me,
but it's not bad.
At In-N-Out, you have an option of Coke,
Diet Coke, 7-Up, Dr Pepper, root beer,
pink lemonade, and Minute
Maid zero-sugar lemonade.
You can also get iced tea, coffee, milk,
and hot chocolate.
I think Shake Shack has one more point
for the soft drinks.
They look pretty good,
and if you describe
something as "like tea,"
I'm going to vote for it.
We cannot forget about the milkshakes.
I love Shake Shack milkshakes.
They have their core flavors
that are always on the menu.
Vanilla, chocolate,
which also has a non-dairy option,
vanilla-and-chocolate, strawberry,
black-and-white,
and cookies and cream.
They do seasonal flavors pretty often.
Right now, they have the
triple chocolate brownie shake
and the Oreo cookie funnel cake shake.
The black-and-white shake
and the chocolate-and-vanilla shake
are actually different things.
I didn't realize this at first.
But this is the black-and-white shake.
This is vanilla custard with fudge syrup
mixed all up in there,
which gives it a little chocolatey taste.
I just feel like it's going to taste
like a chocolate milkshake.
I don't really get why
it's its own flavor.
The vanilla-and-chocolate shake flavor
is just the vanilla custard
and the chocolate custard mixed together.
I'm actually going to take a sip
of the regular chocolate milkshake, too.
This one tastes slightly different.
I feel like the black-and-white
and possibly the vanilla-and-chocolate
just taste very, very similar.
They shouldn't be two separate flavors.
But the chocolate milkshake
tastes like I'm drinking
chocolate ice cream.
It's really, really good.
I do want to taste the non-dairy.
I've never had a non-dairy
milkshake before.
No.
It kind of just tastes
like chocolate almond milk.
Not for me.
I believe this one is the
Oreo cookie funnel cake shake.
It sounds like a lot.
I just feel like I have so many
chocolate shakes sitting
in front of me right now,
and they're all starting to
blend together in my mouth.
I don't know what this tastes like,
but it's not very good.
They do make floats, too.
I love a good float.
This is the Creamsicle flavor.
I believe it's radioactive orange.
I don't know why it's so orange.
Yeah, that's really good.
And this one is the
classic root beer float.
Delicious.
It tastes so good with the
vanilla custard specifically.
If you want something more
classically dessert-y,
you can get their frozen custard,
which comes in vanailla, chocolate,
or dairy-free chocolate.
They really love the dairy-free
chocolate at Shake Shack.
It's a choice.
Let's see how the custard
tastes on its own.
It's delicious.
The vanilla's really, really good.
This is the dairy-free chocolate custard.
No.
In-N-Out has three flavors of milkshake:
vanilla, chocolate, and strawberry.
But you can mix them together
to create whatever flavor
combination you want.
I did not do that. I'm a shake purist.
So I wanted to make sure
that I got the actual
flavors that they offer.
This strawberry shake is so good.
It's so good.
Chocolate.
That's really good, too.
And vanilla.
Don't sleep on vanilla.
People think "Eh, vanilla's basic,"
but this is a good vanilla shake.
You can also get a root beer float,
which is root beer,
and they don't have ice cream on the menu,
so I'm assuming it's vanilla shake.
Whatever it is, it's really good.
Going after A&W.
I think it looks like Shake Shack
has way more milkshake options,
but I think it's just a
lot of the same flavors
reused in different ways.
Joe seemed to really enjoy
the limited options that he had,
so I think maybe quality over quantity.
But we'll say that you
can both have a point.
Starting off by comparing the burgers.
This is an In-N-Out cheeseburger.
Iconic.
Look at that.
So we have one patty
with a slice of cheese,
lot of onion, some lettuce, bun,
and a slice of tomato.
And we're going to do the
same with the ShackBurger.
Top bun.
Our wilted lettuce.
Two teeny tiny tomatoes.
And then we have our patty.
Obviously, I cannot separate
the cheese from the patty.
It's all kind of melted in there.
And then we have our bottom bun.
So a Shack burger is 162 grams.
Point goes to In-N-Out.
If that wasn't enough,
at In-N-Out you can also
get a Double-Double,
which is two patties
and two slices of cheese,
a 3x3,
which is three patties
and three slices of cheese,
and a 4x4, which is,
you guessed it, four patties
and four slices of cheese.
The Shack Burger is also
offered as a double,
so you get two patties instead of one.
Which chain gives you the
biggest amount of fries?
Here is an order of In-N-Out fries,
and we want to weigh them right now.
99 grams.
Shake Shack only offers one size of fries.
Let's see how much they weigh.
An order of fries at
Shake Shack is 190 grams.
Shake Shack bringing
it back with the fries.
That's a point.
In-N-Out gives you four
fountain-drink sizes,
the small, the medium, the large,
and the extra large.
The small at In-N-Out.
Let's do 12.
And the medium,
18 to 19.
We'll be generous and do 19.
Eh, let's do 18. Because
it wouldn't be 19, right?
18.
I mean, this looks like it would be
an extra large in most places.
A lot.
Between 28 and 30.
If only there was a
number between 28 and 30.
The extra large at In-N-Out.
Oh, it's exactly 40 ounces.
Yo!
Drinks at Shake Shack come in two sizes,
small and large.
Let's see how much we
get in the large size.
This is one of the smaller large drinks
I've ever seen from a
fast food casual chain.
So this is 24 ounces of soda.
The large drink comes out to about
a little under 700 milliliters,
or 24 ounces.
I'm reluctantly giving the
point to In-N-Out there,
because I think 40
ounces, too much liquid.
24 is more normal,
but, hey, rules are rules.
Both chains offer milkshakes in one size.
Let's see how much milkshake
you get at In-N-Out.
From here, it looks like
it's exactly 16 ounces.
Good for you, In-N-Out.
Let's see how much milkshake
you get at Shake Shack.
I think that this is 450
milliliters of milkshake,
almost exactly.
Shake Shack milkshake
slightly bigger. One point.
I think it's fair to
say that with fast food,
people want value for their money.
We're going to compare some prices
and assign points based on
how much food you're getting
for what you pay.
An In-N-Out cheeseburger
will cost you $3.75.
That is shockingly cheap.
A cheeseburger at Shake
Shack will cost you $7.49.
OK, so the whole cheeseburger
was 194 grams from earlier,
remember that?
So per 100, that's,
OK, divide the price by
the total gram weight,
which is 194,
but then I multiply that by 100.
So that means it's $1.93 per 100 grams.
A regular cheeseburger at
Shake Shack comes out to
around 138 grams,
meaning that it's about $0.05 per gram,
or $5.42 per 100 grams.
The order of fries that we got at In-N-Out
was $2.30.
Honestly, they should be
paying me to eat these fries.
Anyway, let's also find
out how much it costs
per 100 grams.
It was 99 grams, which was $2.30.
A fry is not even a gram.
Can we just say it's $2.30 for 100 grams?
We've all collectively
agreed that we're fine,
so it's $2.30 for 100 grams.
At Shake Shack, an order
of fries costs $4.09.
An order of fries comes
out to about 190 grams,
making it $0.02 per gram,
or $2.15 per 100 grams.
In-N-Out does seem ridiculously cheap.
I think that's worth a point.
Let's compare nutritional value of items
that are most similar.
A ShackBurger is 500 calories
and contains 30 grams total fat,
12 grams saturated fat,
105 milligrams of cholesterol,
and 1,250 milligrams of sodium.
An In-N-Out cheeseburger is 480 calories
and contains 27 grams of total fat,
10 grams of saturated fat,
60 milligrams of cholesterol,
and 1,000 milligrams of sodium.
The most calorific items
on the Shake Shack menu right now
are the Shake Stack at 770 calories,
the spicy cheese fries
with ranch at 870 calories,
and the Oreo cookie funnel
cake shake at 1,080 calories.
For most calorific items on
the official In-N-Out menu,
we saw online that the
Double-Double with onions
is 670 calories,
and the strawberry shake,
the regular 15- or 16-ounce,
is 590 calories.
Now, as you are aware,
In-N-Out has a secret menu,
not-so-secret menu,
so these calories we found
on third-party sites,
so can't confirm that this is 100% true.
But according to smart
people on the internet,
the 4x4 burger is 1,470 calories,
the animal-style fries is 750 calories,
and
if you get an extra-large
strawberry shake,
it's 1,180 calories.
I'm not giving any points
out for the nutrition.
Live your life. I don't care.
When it comes to ingredients,
In-N-Out prides itself on not freezing,
prepackaging, or
microwaving any of its food.
This actually might be the exact reason
why the fries have such a bad rap.
People really hate the
In-N-Out fries, yes,
including chef David Chang,
who speculates it's because
they don't freeze their fries
when the potatoes are in peak season.
They eventually have to use
potatoes that are out of season,
and therefore not as good.
But then again, they're always bad,
so I don't know about that theory.
Other theories on why In-N-Out
fries aren't very good
include the type of potato that are used
and the way the fries are fried.
They supposedly use Kennebec potatoes,
which is definitely a unique choice
for fast food restaurants.
The go-to is russet potatoes.
While Shake Shack burgers are made fresh,
their infamous crinkle-cut
fries are frozen.
In 2013, they actually
switched from the frozen
Yukon Gold crinkle-cut fries
to hand-cut fries made
from russet potatoes.
Not only were these
fries way harder to make,
but people also just didn't like them.
I'm not kidding, there was
even a change.org petition.
They ended up switching back
to the frozen crinkle-cut fries
in the fall of 2014.
But this time, they worked
with their manufacturer
to remove the artificial
ingredients and preservatives.
I'll admit I don't love Shake Shack fries.
I'm not a crinkle-cut kind of girl.
I'm mainly there for
the burgers and shakes.
But good on them for giving
the people what they wanted.
As for the meat used for in the burgers,
Shake Shack uses a custom blend
of 100% Angus beef.
And In-N-Out uses 100% USDA ground chuck.
Shake Shack burgers are famously served
on Martin's potato rolls.
If you've ever been to
a Shake Shack in person,
you can see rows and rows
of Martin's potato rolls in the back.
The owners, the Martin family,
were exposed in 2020 for backing far-right
Pennsylvania state Sen. Doug Mastriano,
who was seen crossing police lines
during the January 6th
attack on the Capitol.
In 2022, a representative
for Shake Shack told Insider,
"In regards to the actions of individuals
associated with the Martin's company
and their personal political donations,
those are the choices of those individuals
and do not express the
values of Shake Shack.
We continue to be in active
conversations with Martin's
to expression our concern."
Switching to another potato roll
seems to like a very easy thing to do
for a multibillion-dollar
company like Shake Shack,
but what do I know?
In-N-Out gets their
buns from Puritan Bakery
in Carson, California.
The buns are made by using the sponge
and dough process,
which produces buns that
can withstand condiments
and meat juice without falling apart.
Another Shake Shack
ingredient I have to mention
is the frozen custard
that they make in-house.
I'm calling it an ingredient right now
because it serves as a base
for all of their milkshakes,
and I swear, this is
why they taste so good.
Milkshakes are typically
made with ice cream.
Frozen custard has all the
same ingredients as ice cream,
except it also includes egg yolks.
So using frozen custard gives
you an even richer milkshake.
The milkshakes at Shake Shack are dense
and sometimes hard to drink with a straw,
but they taste so good.
In-N-Out was founded in 1948
in Baldwin Park, California.
And Shake Shack started
out as a hot dog stand
in Madison Square Park in 2001.
It officially became the Shake
Shack we know today in 2004.
Wow, In-N-Out's got
some history behind it.
That's got to be worth a point.
In-N-Out has 392 locations in the US,
but all those locations
are only in seven states:
California, Texas, Arizona, Nevada, Utah,
Colorado, and Oregon.
California has the most
locations by far, with 271.
That means 69% of all In-N-Outs in the US
are in California.
Nice.
From the time of filming this,
Shake Shack has 299 locations in the US.
They're not region-specific
the way that In-N-Out
is on the West Coast,
but most Shake Shacks
are on the East Coast.
New York has the most locations, with 49,
but California is catching
up really quickly.
They currently have 40 locations.
Shake Shack is also available
in over 80 countries.
There are over 400 locations worldwide.
I think Shake Shack gets a point there
for the availability.
I like the fact that it's available
not just on the East Coast, but elsewhere,
and even here in the UK
and other parts of the world.
For the most part, I
think these two chains
do exist peacefully,
and I think that's
because they're actually
not very similar.
In-N-Out feels like
this constant, reliable
fast food chain,
and Shake Shack is a fine casual chain
that's constantly adding
and removing things from its menu.
They do a lot of seasonal stuff.
The rivalry is something we
as the customers created.
Everyone loves to compare these two.
You know, I didn't really think there was
much of a beef between
Shake Shack and In-N-Out.
Me personally, if I want Shake Shack,
I want In-N-Out,
I feel like the two don't really overlap
as far as what I want from either one.
That's my personal opinion.
I understand it's two businesses
that are competing.
But I think both have coexisted just fine.
Both chains give off different vibes
that I do think are
inspired by their regions.
In-N-Out gives me more laid-back,
beachy Americana.
Shake Shack feels more minimalist
and muted and modern.
In-N-Out still feels like a traditional
fast food restaurant.
Yes you can eat there,
but the vibe is definitely,
hit the drive-thru and go.
Shake Shack is for sure
on the pricier side.
My go-to order usually
comes out to about $17.
That's $17 for a bacon cheeseburger,
fries, and a milkshake.
The founder described the
concept for Shake Shack
as "fine casual,"
so they're not shying away
from how pricey it is.
This food was less expensive
than almost all the fast food
we've covered on Food Wars.
Also, we got a little over $100
worth of food for this shoot.
It took them maybe seven
minutes to fill that order.
I didn't call ahead.
Went in there, got everything.
Listen, I've had both,
and even though taste
is obviously subjective,
I just think Shake Shack's
burger tastes better.
If you put both burgers in front of me
without me knowing anything about them,
I would always pick the Shake Shack burger
as the better of the two.
Aside from the delicious crispy burgers,
I just like how many options
I have at Shake Shack.
And it's not like they do any one food
better than the other.
I think the chicken
and the vegetarian options are also great.
The only thing I'm not a huge fan of
is the plain fries.
And I still think that they're better
than the plain fries at In-N-Out, so.
When people come and
visit me in Los Angeles,
which is rare, because of my personality,
they are like, "I want to go to In-N-Out.
Not with you, Joe,
but I'm going to go to In-N-Out."
And then later, I find
out that they enjoyed it,
thought it was incredible.